hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
continuing our coverage of the 2018
World Chess Championships between Magnus
Carlsen and Fabiano Caruana today we're
in game number eight Fabiano's playing
the white pieces Magnus is defending
with the black pieces we'll go ahead and
get started with pawn to e4 pawn c5 the
Sicilian offense what Magnus Carlsen has
been going to each and every time he
sees pawn to e4 Knight to f3 knight c6
and then this is where things start to
get a little bit different because we
were used to sing Bishop to b5 but in
the game we see more of the main line
with pawn to d4 pawn takes here Knight
captures the knight down here to f6
Knight to c3 and then pawn to e5 this is
the Lasker Pelican variation something
we don't see all too that often but
right away in move number 6 White has a
very critical move and that is Knight to
b5 now very rarely do you see a critical
move this early but if you're not
familiar with this opening this really
is that the key move here if you think
about other places where white can go to
maybe the knight takes here on a c6 the
pawn recaptures here black now has all
the center pawns he can start to push
forward really control get equality very
easy if instead we see something like
Knight to b3 then Bishop down here
before this is pinning down the knight
to the king this Knight is the piece
that's defending this pawn here on e4
this Knight can freely attack this
White's gonna have to move sub-optimally
just to defend this piece so what this
night here on b5 does is you know if the
bishop board now to come down to b4 you
can play just pawn to a3 forcing the
bishop to move it the bishop now wants
to take the knight can recapture here on
c3 so this is really the only place that
you see now at high level play that why
it's gonna move
- and that is night to be five pawns who
a d6 men up here - d5 and there's a
couple options the main line here is for
the bishop to come here to g5 way less
common is night coming up here to d5 so
nice to see Faviana going outside normal
book lines Knight captures here on d5
really needs to capture here white is
threatening the fork up here on c7 and
it's protected by the other nights here
on d5 so madness takes with his Knights
the pawn recaptures here
the knight comes back here to b8 Magnus
if he wants he could also come to e7 but
also wants to get his bishop involved
into the game so he can castle on the
King side so he opts for playing the
knight back here to b8 and then moving
it over here to d7 so it can come to an
outpost here on c5 or if wants to swing
over here to the King side the board he
can do that as well Fabiano continues
with pawn to a4 and then Bishop to e7
get rid of the castle on the King side I
thought we made C pawn to a6 Fabiano's
really pushing on the Queen side not
really worried about too much on the
Kings side right now this knight on b5
is a problem it's attacking the backward
pawn here on d6 and it's really just
cramping the style that black has on the
Queen side of the board but instead we
see bishop here to e7 Bishop e2 both
sides Castle Knight here to d7 so wants
to open up the opportunity to get this
Knight involved into the into the game
wherever he wants to Bishop here to d2
just wants to activate the bishop also
wants to be able to push forward here to
a5 and still control that with his
bishop also has his rook back here on a1
and then Magnus Carlsen plays pawn to f5
so this is really aggressive for Magnus
on the King side of the board
recognizing that Alright Fabiana has
already pushed on the Queen's now it's
gonna be tough to counter-attack right
now so he decides to push forward on the
Kings side of the board now pawn to a5
as we talked about and now we see the
pond too
a six White has a couple options you
could come back here to c3 this does
block off his Bishop here on d2 from
defending he still has his rook here on
a one but he comes back here to a three
because this does open up the door to
maneuver his knight here to c4 and then
up here to b6 this is a great outpost
another reason he wants the pawn here on
a5 and he can block his own rook off
because he brought his bishop here to d2
pawn here to e4 just trying to push over
here on the kingside needs to get more
space and do something or why it's gonna
just dominate the Queen side of the
board an idea to c4 as we talked about
Knight to e5 just a great outpost in the
center of the board Knight to b6
attacking the rook rook has to move so
rook to b8 f4 so this is just attacking
the knight in the center of the board
black pretty much has to take here and
this is a move called Besant if you
haven't seen him before if you're new to
chess this is a legal move once you're
on the the fourth row here for black and
your opponent moves their pawn to
squares next to you you have one and
only chance to actually take right here
as the legal move Magnus Carlsen did
play that in the game bishop recaptures
here on f3 and then pawn to g5 and this
is pretty interesting no one expected
Magnus Carlsen to play this if you were
watching a commentary or you're
following on Twitter you know all the
grandmasters are giving their feedback
on this game Nakamura actually said that
this did not feel like a Magnus Carlsen
move thought that it was a mistake just
pushing too much in front of his own
King here without a real strong attack
that he can go to so it just comes down
to can Fabiano find a strong enough
attack here to continue and come up with
a victory now we see pawn to c4 f4 from
Magnus Carlsen bishop up here to see
three and then Bishop to f5 and this is
a critical place in at the game if you
start to look at what
beyond oohs trying to do here this night
in the sand aboard is a crucial square
there's no pawn in the center and all
the pawns in front of the King have
really pushed forward so this Knight
feels like a huge piece as far as blacks
defense here so there's a couple ways to
attack this one of the best ways is to
play a move that's going to get rid of
this defender here on d6 Fabiano spent
over 30 minutes on this move and then
played pawn to c5 trying to chip away at
the defense here on d6 now Magnus
Carlsen staring at the board just as
long as Fabiano is trying to figure out
his move then decided yeah the only way
to really respond here is to start
gobbling up material he recognizes he's
in a tough position
Fabiano has all the advantage as far as
being aggressive on board so he needs to
just start exchanging material Queen
takes back here on f3 the pawn takes and
then the rook swings over here to d1 so
yes white gave up some material here but
he is definitely the aggressor he has
two very active rooks here his bishop is
eyeing down his opponent's King side of
the board his knight outpost here it's
blocking both of the rook moves right
now it's also just a pain and aside for
Magnus Carlsen to have to deal with so
after rook a to d1 we see Bishop here to
d6
now as we've talked about before there's
always chess engines going on during
these games boat to help the
commentators go through different
positions and see if what they're
telling the audience makes sense but
also for the average fan to be able to
watch and see what are some of the
options that they could see from the
grandmasters you can even put in your
own lines to see what the supercomputers
think much more advanced than just
normal software you would be running at
home if you were trying to follow along
some of the supercomputers in this
position said that Fabiana was up almost
two pawns in material now that's just
their rating system even though if you
count the material up you would see that
Magnus Carlsen is ahead as far as the
advantage
mostly because of the position and the
attacking opportunities that Fabiano has
they say that he has a huge huge
advantage in the spot they recommend
Queen to h5 really everyone said that
Fabiano had to stay aggressive if you're
gonna give up material and you have all
this material pointing down at your
opponent you have to stay aggressive
that's exactly what Queen to h5 does
unfortunately that's not what Fabiana
does he plays the quiet move pawn to h3
something that I think is fine if you're
looking at this early in the game and
you're trying to stop your opponent
coming down here to g4 many times with
their Bishop trying to pin down your
knight on f3 or their knight comes to f6
and then it can come down here to g4
that makes sense for h3 but I feel like
you need to be more aggressive in this
spot Queens who eh Knight comes back
here to c4 also don't like yes it is
attacking the bishop but just don't like
retreating the material needs to be very
aggressive in this spot Queen down here
to g6 the knight takes there is an
exchange on the board punt up here to h4
so moving to you know using two of his
moves to just push this pawn up here to
h4 we do see the pond take yes this was
defending this pawn right here Fabiano
looking for the exchange right here with
its Queens that's exactly what manage
Carlsen does pawn down here to h5 rook
to e1 Bishop down to a g4 just an
outpost also stopping the rook from
coming over here to h4 taking this
material double pawns on either the H or
the 8th out they're gonna be hard to
hold on to the entire game but it does
stop it momentarily rook up here to f6
defended by the bishop on c3 so it is
safe but we do see an exchange you can
see both sides starting to just trade
off all the material it was not too long
ago the supercomputer thought Fabio and
I had a really good game all of his
major pieces ready for an attack and he
played that pawn to h3 Bishop comes to
h4 takes the material so if you look at
it both sides equal
material getting into the in-game work
over here to f1 a few more moves from
here both sides not going to be able to
do anything
rook to g6 pawn up here to d6 and then
rook to D to do not want to capture
material here yes the bishop is
defending the square here on d7 but then
Rick could take on g4 pawn could take
and after pawn to d7 black would have
lost no way to stop this so in the game
that's not we saw we see a rook to d2
kind of last opportunity that Fabiano
saw rook down to g5 and after 38 moves
both players decide to go ahead and draw
for the eighth consecutive game so we
have four games left I'm personally
hoping for not for more draws but if we
do we will have tie breakers after that
get some bonus chess in but hopefully
you guys enjoyed this one as far as all
the games so far this has been my
favorite I feel like they opened up
Fabiano had a lot of chances just think
you needed to be more aggressive at the
end but thanks so much for watching I'll
see you guys in two days we do have a
break tomorrow so I'll see you in two
days for game number nine